Chris Mannix Jonas from the NBA Summer
League in Las Vegas hey Chris how are
you I mean yeah I just heard about
Selena Gomez and Bieber so I'm doing
pretty well any celebrity sightings in
Las Vegas
uh no no I got here last night so I
haven't quite you know done my
obligatory walk down the strip and look
for them yet so I'll get there well
there's some NBA talent there some stars
there right yeah I mean I was in the gym
last night if you want to have a robust
conversation about Kevin Knox and you
know his his abilities I can happily
break that down off last night okay I
know Nick fans are all excited because
he's had a couple of good games oh yes
oh god I love the overreaction summer
league play I love it I mean guys guys
put up 30 on you know you know people
that'll be working at Starbucks in six
weeks and all of a sudden it's it's uh
it's a big deal you know that they're
very excited about the Kevin Knox dunk
fest that's up I would remind people
that that Nate Robinson literally has
his jersey on the wall up here because
of how he's played and some release past
I wouldn't get too excited about the
numbers how about this guy firkin from
the 76 and we just love his name work on
korkmaz yes yeah he's just Summer League
that he's been a couple of times
fringe NBA guy minutes it did pick up
the competition here is so bad I mean
it's it's weird it's like it's like it's
almost like you have like Golden State
warrior level talent at the top of the
roster and like barely why are you there
Mannix why are you there if the if the
league in any good by everybody here and
you know it's a chance to see everybody
you need to see all in kind of one place
you'll periodically see you know you
want to see the first bacon once he ate
and play and you know see if somebody
put on muscle and and lever it yes
that's how we could I'd uh explain to me
what has happened what will
in the offseason any other major moves
like Carmelo Clint capela anybody's
gonna tip the balance here that makes
makes it even more interesting or less
interesting yeah I mean Carmelo is
interesting because he's Carmelo and I'm
most interested to to see what kind of
role he's willing to take on with his
next team and he's he's at this pivotal
kind of transition point right I mean
he's you know I don't know if Oklahoma
City would have held on to him anyway
but I think they would have had a longer
conversation if he had said to them look
I'll come off the bench I'll be a sixth
man he made there he's making their
decision pretty easy for them by
basically drawing a line in the sand and
all that will carmelo anthony decide
he's willing to be a reserve in this
final chapter in his career if he does
then they'll be you know a dozen teams
out there looking to sign I mean Carmelo
Anthony again second unit guys is a
weapon Carmelo Anthony who is going to
insist on being a starter who is going
to gripe if he's not on the floor in the
fourth quarter that's not a guy more
than one or two teams is going to be
interested in so he is the most
interesting guy I mean the natural
thought is that he winds up with the
Lakers but unless LeBron insists that
Carmelo Anthony winds up there I don't
believe that that the Lakers would show
any real interest in him so I'm really
just to see what happens there with
Carmelo
yeah I'm right there with you on that
because now I'm looking at LeBron
supporting cast and it sounds like he's
handpicking
this supporting cast but what do you
make of the moves that you bring in
Rondo you bring in Miggy you bring in
Lance Stephenson what's this mean oh
it's so goofy it really is and and I
love I love the narrative that's being
pushed out there that people some people
actually are believing that you know
we're getting away from what Miami did
and what Cleveland did we're not going
to surround LeBron James with shooters
we're gonna surround him with
competitors and with playmakers you know
putting aside Rondo
I mean LeBron loves playing with high IQ
players is that how you describe JaVale
McGee is that how you describe Lance
Stephenson
he's gonna wind up like playing through
the post this year he's getting the
immediately double-teamed by by two or
three guys because coaches know that
he's gonna throw the ball out to a 30%
three-point shooter Rondo a 30% 3-point
year in in Lance Stephenson Alonzo ball
who shot we know is suspect I mean the
guys around give Dan just make no sense
and that doesn't even take into account
the brewing like war that could take
place between Rondo and Lonzo and levar
we have to throw in this mix as well I
mean the Lakers doing a hell of a job
selling this narrative that type of team
that will take LeBron into the final
through the final stage of his career
but I think it's total nonsense I think
this is the type of team that
spontaneously combusts right around
midseason oh wow do you disagree I mean
I don't like the supporting cast but I
do look at LeBron turning 34 in December
and I think that at some point you have
to take the San Antonio Spurs approach
to stars and I got a limit his minutes
because I want him to play four more
years or five more years and I that's
what I don't know can I bring in people
who are going to make plays so he
doesn't have to make the play all by
himself however you do that I wouldn't
have brought in McGee Rondo I'm ok if he
can help Lonzo ball a little bit
Stephenson ok you know you brought in a
LeBron defender and now he's on your
team and he's gonna be your you know
draymond Green I guess so I like the
fact that they kept the you know the
younger kids there but LeBron yeah he's
on record I guess that magic you know
consulted him about bringing these guys
in so LeBron is bringing in these three
guys that we're talking about that you
think could be a combustible unit I mean
they're they're very combustible unit
you know one thing about this team is
and this is this I believe like this is
something they like one thing about this
team is their practices are gonna be
great because they're bringing in
competitors with LeBron of course huge
competitor Rondo incredible competitor
has worked really well with younger
players over the last couple of years
they even sin for all his other flaws an
incredibly competitive guy so after a
year last year where they were kind of
like you know the romper room out there
with rap battles and and really no level
of intensity in that locker room it's
going to be a different vibe there but
the one thing that was problematic for
his team last year dad that I see being
problematic again is that not a lot of
guys have equity in this team not a lot
of guys in that locker room are looking
around saying I'm gonna be a Laker for
multiple years I'm invested in him in
the long term health this group this
group but the next contract and we know
no matter what they're saying about
Rondo and Lance at the maguey right now
it's highly likely that none of these
guys are on this team next year when
they go big-game hunting born those big
stars so I worry about you know if a guy
like Rondo is not getting his minutes
what does he say
if blank Steve it's not getting his
minutes what does he say how does Luke
Walton handle all of this in his you
know first foray into this type of
coaching job it just has like got the
ability to spark very quickly in that
locker room he's Chris Mannix Yahoo
Sports joining us Dan Patrick showed
tyloo said he was going to talk to Luke
Walton on held a coach LeBron James what
do you make of it they're friendly and I
think that actually happened last night
here in Vegas least that was the intent
on doing that look guys a great guy and
you know it's not Luke's fault that you
know this franchise player is you know
big cake and it's not like they're gonna
be competitors for the next you know few
the Cavaliers are gonna go through a
really painful rebuild similar even to
what they went through in 2010 so a nice
gesture by ty to do something like that
is Luke Walton safe I don't know I mean
look he's safely succeed I mean it's
it's kind of a cop-out answer but it's
true you know one thing that works
against Luke is you know not only is he
not LeBron guy but he's not really
magics guy either I mean the magic came
in and Rob palinka came in after Luke
Walton was hired he was brought in by
Mitch Kupchak and and that front office
and as we've seen countless times you
know general managers executives like to
bring in their own guys you
LeBron into the mix who's gonna have an
enormous voice not just on the roster
but but on the coaching staff I think
he's gonna have to succeed this season I
don't know what success really looks
like I mean you talk to two different
people some people within the Lakers say
look we're we could be a 55 60 win team
mm I don't really see it I mean I think
LeBron with this group is probably worth
10 wins but he might not be worth more
so I think he's at least got to get into
the playoffs
and have some of these young guys
trending upwards did DeMarcus Cousins
have any other options none zero I mean
the Boston stuff was was not really an
option at at one point but what he just
when he had no lucrative offers and
really there was zero I mean he talked
to the pelicans he talked to the Lakers
but New Orleans and and literally every
other team that I talked to about causes
Dan their their number one concern was
not the long-term contract but we don't
even know what we're paying for in year
one
so whatever whatever we give cousins if
it's a four-year deal 80 million they
looked at it as like a three-year deal
an 80 million because cousins next year
he's probably gonna come back anywhere
February and he's probably not gonna be
a hundred percent not during that time
so they didn't make he didn't get a
single real offer or single offer period
over the first week of free agency I
give him credit you know as soon as he
realized that that wasn't coming he
stopped he pivoted and said you know
what I'm gonna win a championship I'm
gonna go to a great culture and I'm
gonna kind of try to turn my reputation
around and position myself well for the
summer of 2019 if this goes well for
DeMarcus Cousins he is gonna enter free
Aegis real chance of recouping that max
level contract it's autism thank you
Chris we appreciate it we look forward
to seeing you soon
July 30th hair coming off haircut day
for Chris Mannix all right have fun out
there behave all right yeah that's
Christmas Yahoo Sports senior NBA rider
not junior NBA rider no he's a senior
NBA writer for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience
2:39 on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]